the input session regarding
redistricting
advised that the session will be video
and audio recorded should be
subsequently placed online and being
publicly available
this is not a typical meeting of the
house with senate committees and will
not be attempted by all committee
members
this means appearing and down that
county at the belmont mill staff general
court has worked to secure places to
hold these sessions statewide and i'm
grateful to staff and the organizations
that control the use of the facility for
allowing us to use them
and a big big thanks to the general
court staff and community services
they have to get here early and make all
this work somehow thank you guys for
that
so this is the meeting of the senate and
house redistricting committees as a
result we have members of both the house
and senate here with us tonight senator
uh thank you i think i can talk loud
enough that that might be able to pick
me up too uh i am james gregg i am the
chair
of the senate special committee on the
redistricting
uh senator birdsell will be back in a
minute and i'll have her introduce
himself in a second
but i do want to say a couple of things
uh senate rules uh
don't allow you to cheer clap or boo
okay
so we don't we don't want the outburst
if you want to say something the mic
will be here we will accept input on
redistricting from everyone in the room
that wants to speak
so please refrain from
other expressions
uh as i said i am the chair of the
special committee on redistricting
and
i'm also the chair of election law
and municipal affairs
and the vice chair of health and human
services
and i'm almost damped enough that
senator berkshire
is back though
we'll give her the microphone for her to
introduce yourself
hi hi my name is regina horton state
senator for district 2018 which
encompasses the towns of
hampstead dairy in windham
i'm vice chair of election law and chair
thank you representative stephen smith
sullivan county district 11 and deputy
speaker of the new hampshire house by
sheriff's committee
representatives please introduce
yourselves
sure good evening uh representative
glenn turcotte i'm from barrington
stratfor county district four
i'm a senior advisor in the house
majority office i serve on this
committee labor committee
good evening i'm marcus smith i
represent durham and madbury
county
westminster chesterfield and paysdale
and then
this community might serve on healthcare
[Music]
in addition to serving on this committee
i also serve on the election
thank you
as this meeting will be placed online
and is being watched i want to take this
opportunity to speak to the overall
process particularly in that house
information on the redistribution
process can be found on the general
court website once there if you look
down a little and to the right you'll
find links for both the house and senate
redistricting committees there you'll
find past meeting minutes
upcoming meeting information and any
other documents that have been uploaded
uh one of these
we don't need that
i'm going to try to shortcut this whole
thing one of the things you'll find
among other things there is a link for
meeting minutes and recordings and
that's where the video that is being
taken here tonight will be found you can
also find them on youtube house of
representatives
this process that appears throughout the
country over 10 years after the federal
census has completed
population data is used to create
districts for representation at all
levels of government here in new
hampshire our constitution says that the
responsibility for the creation of those
districts is that of the legislature
the districts to be redrawn in new
hampshire will be congressional
executive council state senate state
representative county commissioner and
delegates from the state party
convention
there are handouts here tonight with
some information for you that
information is more detail on belmont
county from the house representative
side it would be helpful for you to
comment on things that you might think
are important for your district in
belmont county but you can of course
make comments on other districts also
we've done this event in every county
and
my own nuggets the reason we're going
out to talk to people that live here is
some towns naturally do business
together
sometimes like in my district without a
four-wheel drive and eight inches of
ground clearance you can't drive from
one to the other and stay in the county
it's those nuggets that we can't get by
looking at a map that we really want to
hear about
there are sign up sheets for people who
want to talk microphone up here for you
to speak into and since we're recording
it's particularly important that you use
the mic so the sound is picked up
with that
first up and i apologize in advance i am
a habitual name butcher
good evening
members of the special district game
committee
my name is don house and i'm a resident
of belmont new hampshire
i created warren article number 26 on
fair non-partisan registered scheme
that appeared on belmont's march 2021
election
this warrant article passed for the
strong majority of voters expressing
their preference
for a fair non-partisan redistricting
process
74 other towns in new hampshire has
similar resolutions
transparency and fairness are crucial
to restore voter confidence in our
election process
my view
of transparency and fairness is the
following
many hearings should be open for remote
testimony via zoom or other technology
one-way streaming is not sufficient
forcing voters to come in
to indoor meetings restrict
participation
and forces voters to choose between
their health and democratic
process i ask you to offer this option
craft maps should be available with
sufficient time for public review and
commentary
i want to see the math before your
community votes on them
an independent non-partisan group of new
four
five towns within belmont county
qualify for their own separate
representatives according to their
constitution these towns are american
gilbert captain tilton and gilman
i would respect the outcome of this
process to provide these towns with
their own representation not share those
other towns
and finally
my view of transparency and fairness is
the district should be competitive and
reflect communities of interest
as a belmont exposure i expect the end
result of this process is that belmont
will continue to have two of their own
state representatives
and continue to share our volatile
district with another town or city
at the belknap county resident
i would like to see less fragmentation
of our various building districts
don't have county is a small town and
doesn't need to be powerful in so many
different districts
in the u.s conversational district
center harbor is part of district 2 and
the rest of the county is part of
council three towns are in one district
and the restaurant another
you have a choice ensuring democracy can
be done in a fair and open process
i hope you choose this option and avoid
the pitfalls and controversy that were
associated with the process of 2011.
in closing thank you for listening
i look forward to the opportunity to
provide feedback on the draft maps and
another similar session and i hope you
will be sharing information about the
next steps in the process soon
next we have
audio
[Music]
good evening are members of the
redistricting committee my name is
claudia ferber and i'm the new hampshire
registered voter when you die from the
time of government
today i have questions from the canadian
and ask them to think about how the
district will affect my community
and ensure that voters and villains tend
to get their representation
first why doesn't the town family can
have an exclusive seat in the enhanced
staples of representatives
the constitution said the town of city
must have a population of more than
three thousand four hundred and
forty-four people to have these students
succeed
wilmington meets this threshold
according to the 20-20 year census
met this threshold in 2010
because of the 2010 redistricting
elington and alton shared two seats from
the state house of representatives and
launched material seat when called team
honestly
did you know that killington kept the
war in carnival for 35 years
in march in 2021
asking for an exclusive seat
and a fair transparent and non-partisan
redistricting process
hopefully you read the letter the march
15 letter sentence different speaker
packard and senate president morris from
the town of gilmington's selectmen
who also serves as the new hampshire
state senate chaplain
vincent the academy and evan connell
the selectmen asked on behalf of the
hillington voters for an exclusive seat
in a fair transparent and nonpartisan
redistricting process
and most importantly they emphasized
without gerrymandering
why does billington share to see
metropolitan and run for tyrio's secret
final step
other than sharing land owners
billington does not share any municipal
services
our tax base is quite different
one has to ask was this german mandarin
in billington did you know that we had
our own district in the past
until the
until the end of the 1960s and then
again for a period in the 1970s
at that time george b ross jr who
resides still in bennington represented
wilmington and served 14 years in the
house and was speaker of the house from
1975 to 1980.
in 2010 as previously stated he district
and changed things hillington and alton
became one district sharing the two
house seats
and one cultural secret also in
birmingham
and next we look at
why does belmont county have three new
hampshire state senate districts one can
travel north to south east to west of
belmont county in less than one hour
currently belmont county has towns and
cities divided into three districts
with towns and cities from grafton
stratford and merrimack counties
this does not make sense
gilmington is currently in district six
and she is a new hampshire state senator
with new durham farmington rochester
alton and boston
the only commonality is that often in
durham have a common land boundary
i ask you as the committee to consider
my following request
redistrict so wilmington and alton each
has an exclusive seat in the new
hampshire house of representatives
redistrict the new hampshire state
senate seat so that billington's
representation
is in a district with only towns within
belmont county
and third scheduled public hearings
before the legislature votes on the
redistricting now
my last request is to ensure that this
20-20-21
redistricting process is conducted with
[Music]
is a very difficult one
but it is extremely important
these 10-year lifespan
it's inevitably done correctly now
unfortunately
so
i thank you again
for being here
to see
seeking input into this process
more importantly i thank you in advance
for coming back here to hold a similar
session
[Music]
instead we were given two seats to share
a role
and once he shared with mindset
and all
filmington has a very different place
than all
we share very little except a border
[Music]
our tax structure is very different from
all of us
because of the total lack of
transparency and fairness in the 2011
the next thing that could happen
is placing us in a different way to
particularly
we could also follow the constitution
i am including
in my canva
uh this copies um by including this
statement a copy of the letter from the
gilmanton board of selectmen
to the leaders of the new hampshire
house and the rancho center
and also a copy of the war topic that
was voted on at our time meeting in
march
based on the overwhelming bipartisan
vote
435 yes
125 dollars
in support of warren article 18
which is however new hampshire
resolution
of fair and non-partisan disciplines
our board of selection of urge that the
district intimidates
ensure a fair and transparently just
employment without
gerrymandering by owning public meetings
such as you are here
and they're going to be given a single
non-shared representative in the new
[Music]
elizabeth
since we must educate ourselves we can
take pride in that purchase because it
is where our children are future
but the situation is this
with the same service of education
the often resident must only buy an
average payer of shoes or a discount
store bicycle they get the same result
that paid much less money
i feel differently about this situation
as a result of gilmanton and similarly
situated down further to develop
the policies of the state get taxes
so we are very likely to have different
views on this subject
it is a disease of the current political
climate that we can look at something
that has a plan
that has a plain truth on its face and
would be like an example of doing this
after that
i would like to join the gilbertson
to ensure fair and effective
representation in the nature orders
without securing them
we'll also join them in further urging
the general court to carry on the
redistricting fair and transparent way
through public needs without favoring
any particular party and to include
communities of influence and to minimize
multi-seat sisters
and elizabeth
[Music]
thank you and
i don't envy the task that you have been
assigned
or have been volunteered for
as you know under our constitution we
have 400 state representatives
every town
and every city
in new hampshire i would be willing to
death
wants to have their own exclusive
representative
you can't do that
when you're limited to 400
representatives we think they'll have a
lot more representatives
so that every town could have their own
exclusive representative
i have the privilege of serving in
belknap district 2
which is a multi-town district between
guilford and narrative
i just like to make sure that the
members of the committee have a little
step back a little bit in history
when i first ran
in 2016
there was no party primary
and there were two representatives from
meredith
and two representatives from guilford
were elected and one of those
representatives from narrative became
the chair
of the county delegation
17 and 18 we had two for meredith and
two from gilbert
the next biennium
the election was
from meredith and two from guilford
because i've grown fourth candidates
i don't recall whether there was a
partner primer and i wasn't involved in
that right as i took time off
around the 2020 for the 2012 miami
we had the primary the party primary
and we ended up with
three representatives from guilford and
one for meredith although there was
there was a candidate from an additional
candidate for meredith who did not make
it past the primary
so over each biennium there's been a
back and forth
between two people from there or one
people from there whatever and back and
i wasn't going to come to the meeting
because i i trust
the members of this committee to do
their duty under the constitution
this is
redistricting is and has been since the
beginning of our republic
a political matter
and is to be decided by the legislatures
and i'm assuming that you know your duty
and you will do today
that being said
uh i had been contacted by one person
from meredith
who was vehement that i needed to
advocate that narrative should have its
own exclusive representative
and i indicated that i thought that the
committee would do its duty under the
constitution
what however that works out with the
redistricting
it
so happens that while i live in
guildford
i do represent the people in narrative
and i've carried the votes in narrative
several times
i have been touched on a number of
occasions the town manager in narrative
and we have discussed
how to deal with the donor town issue on
school funding where meredith is a donor
town and doesn't like it so i'm trying
to
represent
the people of both towns in my district
we have four reps i think they all do
that
i think that the multi-town districts
are just a fact of life because of the
limitations of the number of reps we
have available
and i just urge you to
keep that in mind and do your duty as
you see it under the constitution under
the court cases i don't see any problem
with multi-town districts uh belmont
county i think he's very well
represented and all the towns are well
so
[Music]
good evening i want to thank
both the senate representatives and the
representatives from the house
very very important
and i'm very pleased that we're
able to
share with you our concerns and our
hopes with regard to resistance
let me say at the outset i i am a county
commissioner i am not here as a county
professional
i'm here as a
[Music]
i think in this context
has two very important components
one is
[Music]
the vote
major thing
i think is really reflecting
a lot in the
way in which
our house of representatives has been
structured
i mean 400 representatives stationed
well no
is unusual
and i think it does indicate a
commitment to localized representation
to the extent that it can be basically
[Music]
and
divide 400 into the census number and
give them the magic number to be huge
for guidance in instructing
the house districts
it's not a guarantee it's going to be
344 across the board
the constitution itself will be supreme
court cases indicate that reasonable
aviation
is allowed
now let me make one suggestion about
walnut county
belmont county has the fewest
municipalities
of any county in the state
one city and 10 towns
and 18 representatives
so you've got a little bit easier task
to work on with regard to velvet county
and
i think the whole idea of condemnation
districts
is potentially
dangerous
and let
[Music]
in 2000
the legislature saw fit to create
district 5
in delhi county four towns
seven representatives
four towns at 40
population of the county
now the idea of localized
representation
so i got shocked with that
in 2008
of the seven representatives
[Music]
now
looking at
the current situation
i'm very sympathetic with the
position being taken by the people
i mean gilmanton has gone at least
two of the nine years in the last 10
years without is
without a person from government
representative
and
the
filmington
barnstead
alton
area
if you look at
belmont
county if you look at uh alton
if you look at filmington and if you
look at barnsley all of them have the
magic number all over at three four four
four
however millington
is somewhat
slightly over
i would suggest that you give serious
thought
to giving one seat
to call them one seat
again
and a combination
to
barnstead
and all
they do share in a hospital
they also share a superintendent of
schools
now tax structure is different
barnstead does not have frontage on
plate one of the sockets all i know
the kind of impact that they can make
on the tax structure
but there is a commonality of interest
there
and i think that that is fair to all
concerns i mean i think that
alton deserves a separate representative
barnstead deserves a separate
representative and gilbert who deserves
a separate representation
and certainly barnstead and all of them
are in close proximity and they do have
the commonality of interest that i
mentioned
so to me that is a very clear solution
to redistricting in that area
now when it comes to guild
[Music]
situation that i described earlier is
going to occur and we may end up with
four in the same town
yet
but uh the
three to one is
in my
mind and
here
quite clearly milford
meets the threshold
[Music]
america is
three percent on the threshold
yeah
or two representatives
when they're minus the magic number by
three percent
i mean i think including them is a
reasonable deviation from the standard i
would urge you to create
separate districts for the two
and give each one to two representatives
that they deserve
now the other
suggestion that i would urge you to
consider
the city of laconia
is two percent short
of hitting the number of them just by
five representatives
the city of laconia
is
i think makes up 26
of the population of delta county
and also
representatives would make up 26 of the
delegation
i mean that strikes me as a
pretty strong
argument in favor of giving laconia
an additional representative
and i would add to that
laconia the city of latonia has got some
issues some problems
above and beyond
the issues of problems that
of the towns including my town
i think it's very important that laconia
have
a strong
viable
delegation
in concord
and
be given the full number of
representatives that could be reasonably
uh
given and deleted by are called
by the population situation
the other thing i would mention to you
is
[Music]
uh by about a couple of
uh census periods
i've shared representatives and have two
representatives
uh philippines clearly meets the
threshold number
sanborn does not
yet
and san martin is off the number by
about 12
so it's not quite the
swipe deviation that i talked about
meredith
i i think if you if you really want to
give a faith to localized representation
it's not a big leap
to give each of those towns their own
separate representatives
i hope i have not uh carried us too far
into the weeds i apologize for
the journey this sort of
i want to thank you again for the
opportunity to
share the concerns and ideas with you
and i do hope after you come up with
your preliminary maps
i know that it's a burden for all of
them
but it would be very very nice for us to
have the same opportunity to discuss
those preliminary maps when they're
actually
put together
with that let me thank you again
[Music]
representative
county district six but um
so it's a pleasure to be here in belmont
county
[Music]
maybe i will take it off so
just for the duration of my remarks um i
actually do some written testimony which
deals with a plan for redistributing
belmont county i'd get a very there is
some fairly nice
software that the committee has but it
is not to the best of my knowledge been
available republic 10 years ago
the software eventually was made
available probably was actually quite
quite user friendly so that part of the
and uh
i don't know whether
it is to me the 2020 software is
probably similar but it has not been
made public and uh of course also
freezing one first issue of these
meetings we're having to meet with no
plan to comment on and it certainly
would be nice to have a hearing or some
sort of process
when when a plan is finally
finally publicized for the public and
legislators to comment on john last time
last time the plan was presented right
before the deadline for what they call
the retained bills
and was basically presented as a
favorite favorite complete and he went
very long
session with the chairman of the
community
each of the districts um
and then that was the end of the meeting
that was that was uh
mercy from enfield who actually he must
have done was not gerrymandering too
badly because he actually lost his
re-election bid
first of all for the
council of the district 2 is a bad joke
i think of the valinsky built because of
a very high profile um
counselor who
represented us for most of the last 10
years he also called the van ostern bell
for the warmington belt and there's
obviously
no logical reason why statistics should
have been drawn that way
so i hope
the committee will find a more
reasonable
reasonable plan there's a pretty good
one here in this handout from
the mapathon but that's for them to talk
about um
the senate district if you take
um the nomad counties uh ten thousand
people over
uh what it takes to senate district so
it'll be probably fairly simple to
take two towns totaling ten thousand
of the district and then you have a nice
uh
when they still get this just the right
size um percent that throws off the
that's how it goes probably done very
simply just eyeballing it by uh putting
leaving
alternate bar instead of the district
exchange where they are down and putting
wrestling counting or anticipated so
that's actually really simple i don't
worry the effects coping on all the
other districts
so
my main objective current plan on our
state constitution specifies that state
representative suffered continuous the
current plan was put together in 2012 as
others have accommodated includes a
district which fails to meet even that
simple requirement
go for the emeritus foundation way out
in middle lakeland
yet as
as you know they're in one state rep
district so
that doesn't meet down i don't think
that really meets any rational
definition of contiguous we have a
similar situation in
stratford county we have two districts
which means
deep in the woods and actually one of
the two towns is
utero which borders uh
down that county
and uh yes theoretically actually
theoretically the law doesn't actually
prohibit us from drawing the state up
just to the county lines but that's a
very bad idea because the state
represents the beach county are also the
legislative bodies
[Music]
which is something all the reps know and
probably
um so anyway so definitely that district
that should never have been drawn that
way
[Music]
also
article 11 part 7 the same one which
specifies the constitution also states
in part with the population of the town
reward according to the last federal
census has been a reasonable deviation
of the ideal population for one of our
representatives the town reward shall
have its own district of one or more
representative seats and that i'm not
going to be the whole thing and then it
goes on about
and they'll put excess populations by
three at large or for ontario districts
conforming to acceptable deviations
so we meet legislation as we the
legislators we decide whether it's
reasonable acceptable
we do have to take federal voting rights
law into account include the principle
of one person one vote
now in 2012 the political decision was
made it was actually
i was around i was in the legislatures
kind of unclear exactly who made it but
someone made the decision
that they could vary by more than 10
which is plus or minus five percent and
that was uh supposedly justified by
something voting rights along which is
actually now obsolete it was a
it was a safe harbor provision for
districts
um petitions for basically for majority
minority district districts have a large
number of racial minorities
new hampshire has i think
no
majority of minority districts um i
guess it would be possible to draw one
in manchester or nassau but not the work
of the
[Music]
more than that um
uh
since we hit we're a small state with a
large legislature and i was kind of
horrified by making even larger i think
it's already um almost unworthy and
large as it is and certainly we had a
hard time recovering from the pandemic
just because of the large number of
members we have made things more
difficult than smaller bodies such as
the state senator most other
state legislation
um also state regime districts
because traditionally they can't cross
county lines that certainly not advise
you to start across the county lines
it's just going to create more problems
and we're down the city where it's can't
be split into
now an extra neighborhood vermont is
also a small state with a
large legislature in fact um
it's about the same ratio of residents
to state reps over there as it is on our
side of connecticut river
they got away 10 years ago the plan
where state draft cities varied by 20
plus and minus ten even though they have
fewer restrictions
you can split towns vermont but for my
legislation allowed to split towns in
two which
you guys um can't
and uh
anyway first part of the joint
[Music]
18.498 representatives out of four
hundredths um
they actually one time in new hampshire
needs to deal with that problem by
having talents only have representatives
part of the ten year cycle but that's
not allowed anymore
on the other hand we don't have to worry
about the ward boundaries it's just a
rather small city
it's just barely big enough for five
representatives but has six wards so
there's really not
many supposed values some things you can
splitting it apart and sticking with
other channels to make the numbers work
better but you know there's very there's
you know basically it's pretty easy
just give the county a five district to
and i created the plan
actually if we have 18 reps actually
that our new number is not three
thousand four hundred and forty floors
industry
thousand five hundred and thirty nine
eighteen reps and uh
[Music]
eight point eight percent below the uh
for the lean ideal ratio meredith if you
have two reps it's three point three
percent below the rational
and i'm not the person that saved it you
give it a five year district two percent
those
[Music]
if you give it two reps the deviation is
11.8
and that was probably why meredith and
joshua were put together to make the
numbers work better
belmont would get two drafts of plus six
um sanfordton is a big problem because
it's uh it shares a long long slight
land boundary with uh
with new hampton but there's only only
roads that connectivity number three and
the interstate so i stuck it in until 10
and then it gives you two reps and it's
one point four percent over the ideal
ratio you'll pretend i gave it one rep
fourteen point five three percent over
the ratio and
finally i did stick alton and barnstead
together the three rep district which of
course you could have
probably wouldn't want to have one for
each town and then the florida and that
would be some other deviation but it's
4.6 so that's
that plan um
whether or not that's probably not the
plan that's
it's not necessarily the only good plan
or ideal plan but
um it would pass muster with with the
federal uh
webcast monsters federal voting rights
tomorrow
especially since it's it's changed since
10 years ago so that plus or minus 5
basically
something that
didn't even apply 10 years ago 20 years
ago applies even less now you
don't have to
other considerations
you are allowed to consider those and of
course also
communities of interest all those things
you talk about um
we are legally allowed to do it because
the last in the last cycle of
representatives that we can only look at
the numbers and we can ignore everything
else
[Music]
and the other thing is like other things
i'd like to tell you i told you this is
traffic county as i hope
first of all it would be nice to have
some sort of here or some type of
process where
you can actually comment
formally
on the plan other than through the
[Music]
registered committee's
hearings with the representatives on the
committee so i hope i hope we can do
that
somebody people are probably aren't
drawing up plans because the software
has been as i know it has been obtained
people have been working on it that no
plans have been publicized
i also can get a little bit earlier like
last year
we were only a few weeks before the
final deadline and that's
that's that's not so much a big problem
for state reps but some of us were
probably baffled by the state senate
candidates executive council candidates
last time they had no idea where the
district lines were going to be drawn a
lot were drawn in places very different
from where they've been in the previous
10-year cycle and probably different
certainly in district 2 adopted anybody
i doubt that anybody was really
expecting them to draw a little about
one or two times wide all the way across
the state from pinchatella to ramos that
was probably a total surprise
everyone who wasn't
everybody except the people who actually
drew up the plans so i'd like i think
it'd be fair to get just done a little
bit earlier
and also uh
there's probably going to be legal
challenges with any plan we draw and i
know we hate lust and we think it's a
terrible thing that law says but there's
going to be some and it might be
it might be a good idea to give those a
little bit more time to play out so now
one of the things the federal court
decisions was because with plus and
minus 5 they
the as i recall they expressed some
doubt about whether they thought that
was unnecessarily restrictive but there
wasn't really time to
fight that particular issue out and
there was um
it was within our curve you decide what
was reasonable so basically
they disoriented they thought we made an
unreasonable
determination where the reasonable
deviation was so that's uh
so anyway that's why we say good luck
with the plan it's a pretty it's a
pretty difficult task and no one's going
to be pleased with the result no matter
i hope you do a better job than we did
10 years ago which was not
you know pretty ugly so hopefully better
this time
thanks
[Music]
my name is yuji i'm a resident of
america
and i want to begin
by providing my credentials as an expert
on new hampshire's related communities
i'm an eighth generation new hampshire
native i was born in wolfeboro i spent
all 70 of my summers in the lakes region
working hart's turkey farm in the 1960s
in the
1975 moved to meredith my late husband
where we raised our family
of course my little girl cousins still
call me the connecticut cousin because
my father was from connecticut and that
my mother was into the post-graduate
year at brewster academy after world war
ii
my work
and volunteer activities have brought me
to most of the towns in the lakes region
i know this area
very well
my local knowledge is pertinent because
decisions are being made that affect the
rights of our citizens
the lines which are drawn connecting
communities need to be executed with a
clear understanding
of local conditions
from europe
all new england seems the same and the
difference between rhode island and
vermont are all invisible
the entire lakes region may seem the
same from outside the region
but it's not
the beauty and intent of new hampshire's
massive house of representatives
is to provide local representation
it's part of our unique and proud
position
when communities who do not share common
interests and girls are combined into
one legislative district as with
meredith milford
both communities are disenfranchised
and i know that that is neither the
intent nor the purpose of this
commission
although american gilbert may appear
similar from afar and share common
boundaries some are inevitable from
misaki
they are unrelated in all the important
ways
when meredith had his own
representatives they were known in the
community
we would run into them at the dump the
post office and the borrowed hearts
they shot at the local stores
new kids at the local schools belonged
to the local service clubs
they were part of the community
i'm sure that's true for guilford too
although i don't know because even
though i have friends in real time
and have done business in guilford
i don't see how they
and that is the problem of the current
configuration
the geography which includes lakes and
mountains affects the travel problems
and there's no natural connection
between meredith and guilford
none although that location in the
normal lake may fulfill the letter of
the law which requires a common boundary
the spirit intent of the law are
frustrated
by combining the two towns both are
disenfranchised
right now meredith is underrepresented
but the same could happen to guildford
and it's interesting because i
understand we have
somebody from guilford who's
representing meredith who spoke earlier
and i had i got him i was on the
elevator with him i asked him to put a
mask on actually we didn't
but i had no idea who he was and i am an
active
participant in narrative life and then
late surgery
so i encourage you to repair this
mistake and return narrative to its own
district
thank you for your time and attention
[Music]
meredith
six
[Music]
male chair and members of the special
redistricting committee
my name is lee montana and i'm from
meredith
and i'm grateful for this opportunity to
speak
at this very important public session
on an extremely important subject
the constitutional nonpartisan
democratic procedures of
redistricting every new hampshire voter
has the right to expect this special
committee to follow the nonpartisan and
independent process for fair and
transparent parents redistricting
in 2010
red map
[Music]
appropriate red map
short for redistricting majority project
was adopted by the republican state
leadership committee of the united
states
to increase republican control
of congressional seats
as well as state legislators largely
through determination of electoral
district boundaries
the project made effective use
of partisan gerrymandering
relying on specific mapping software
where there was a democratic majority
but which they could swing towards
republican
with appropriate redistricting
the project was launched in 2010
and estimated to have cost the
republican party around 30 million
dollars
redmapp's own website proudly sums it up
best
quote
the party controlling that effort
controls the drawings of the maps
shaping the political landscape for the
next 10 years
unquote
even karl rove
took to the wall street journal saying
quote he who controls redistricting
controls congress
unquote
this was not the outcome that the
framers of the new hampshire
constitution intended
when they addressed redistricting after
whether republican independent
or democrat
the majority of new hampshire voters
understand that it is advantageous to us
all to have fair transparent and
nonpartisan redistricting procedures
no matter which party polls the majority
in conquered
unfortunately in 2011 these procedures
were not only absent
in new hampshire but deliberately
obfuscated and hidden from the public
by party politicians who formed the
committee
and the result was a very partisan
arrangement of voting districts which
quite frankly to a great many new
hampshire voters
was appalling shameful and very
undemocratic
in 2011
decisions were made by three politicians
and held in secret behind closed doors
public meetings were held after very
short notice with no maps available for
the public to see
our state legislators were only allowed
to view the maps a few days before
voting on the districts
any opposition for improvements for
silence
and so we new hampshire voters
are here today in solidarity
to tell you
that we expect you
the newest appointed members of this
special committee
to act independently and without party
bias
when drawing up the redistricting maps
for 2021
and the next 10 years
we're asking you to fix these maps and
you can request if you like
the organization
fair maps
i'm sure they'll be happy to assist you
over the last 10 years
new hampshire voters have been denied
our rights to choose our elected leaders
due to gerrymandering which must end now
we would like to see you restore
a fair and transparent voting system in
our state by 2021
and last but not least i am from
meredith
i lived there most of my life and voted
since 1970.
prior to 2010 meredith was its own
singular voting district with two town
representatives
this is not the case
nor has it been since 2011
when we were coupled together through
redistricting with guilford
numerous other towns have also been
denied their historically independent
districts
meredith needs to have our district and
representatives reinstated
as it was prior to 11 2011
making it once again comply correctly
within the constitution
again thank you for this opportunity and
i truly hope that the voters of bellam
county and new hampshire can rely on you
our newest committee members to fulfill
your duties with honesty and integrity
and carry out fair non-partisan
transparent redistricting according to
the law
thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
um so good evening is the chair um
members of the special committee
my name is steve merrill and i've lived
in meredith for the past 20 years
i'm here to express my concern for the
future of ourselves
over the past decades
i've witnessed the deterioration of
norms and the decay of our four
institutions
a deterioration which has accelerated
over the past decade
a theory of deterioration that began in
our nation's capital but has somehow
liked to operate state why did we let
that happen
a deterioration that if left unchecked
could undermine the very foundation of
certainly one significant influence on
this insidious decay has been a partisan
guarantee which has grown more and more
powerful with the information technology
revolution
over the past 30 years
flying computing technology
combined with modern data analytics
enable politicians to leverage voter
against the will of the people
just as facebook google
apple can predict which ads you're
likely to
to click on
voter analytics to predict how groups of
in 2010 a waiver of republicans swept
into our state and boldly asserted their
authority over our voting system
the germany during that result left one
party with an unfair advantage in the
election
elections for the ensuing decades
to achieve this goal legislators chose
to sacrifice the independence of merit
and marrying other towns
by taking away their representatives
though meredith leans republican or
rather
in because of this fact
we were
combined gilbert to form a district with
four representatives
never mind that the only order we shared
was across the lake and have nothing in
common share no institutions no dump no
no schools nothing
the obvious reason was to increase the
house uh increase the number of house
seats where there are next today
and it worked
and so to the gentleman the
representative who spoke before me yes
there have been representatives from
meredith
that
have won but they're always republican
because an independent or a democrat is
unknown in guildford for obvious reasons
we don't share anything in congress
nobody wouldn't know them yet but
the results of the 2010 gerrymandering
also had a profound impact on our state
senate
from 2010 to 2020 republicans controlled
the state senate for eight of the 10
years in spite of losing the total vote
over that period
that is the combined vote of all 24
districts by about 1.6
the democrats needed a wave
of their own to take the chamber for
just two of those 10 years
in 2018 democrats won the total vote
count for those 24 seats by 8
but only won 14 of the 24 seats
in 2012
the totals were 51-49 for the democrats
yet the republicans maintained control
of the chamber 13-11.
in 2014 the tally was 50.3 to 49.7 so
pretty close republicans again
maintained control this time picking up
a seat 14-10.
um
you heard that right democrats won more
votes but lost the elections in 12 14
and 16.
i'm sorry in 16 the founder of what
publicly finally won the vote so the
[Music]
percent margin how fair is that
we have an evenly divided state
and yet 16 of uh of 24 state senate
districts were controlled by a single
parties
for the entire decade that's all
10 years one party controlled 16 of the
24. we never flipped because of the
journey the packing of votes into a
certain distance
for the good of our state for the good
of our people please please restore
fairness to our
electoral process and please restore
meredith's independence that you've
heard from so many others give us back
okay
makeup
for four
um
i have a question for you
i'm really curious how many of you when
you're speaking to people outside of new
hampshire
brag
about our
citizen government
that we have so many representatives
people know who the representatives are
i know i did
when i lived in farmington for 29 years
we had
the population there right now is six
thousand nine hundred and thirty people
we had two representatives and
i saw people that subscribed earlier
town meeting that ball games at the bank
at community events there were people
that i knew
so when i had a question about what was
going on or wanted to give input it was
really easy you could sometimes just do
it
[Music]
i it took me a little bit to catch on
but
i'm shocked
and all the years lived in gillington
behind zero
zero representatives from dungeon
there's not a single person that i came
across
get to know
and have those kind of conversations so
they can't get to know me what do i care
about and i can't get to know them so we
can have those dialogues back and forth
so i
as other people have requested
would request that
you restore the spirit and the
functionality of our citizen legislature
i would like to once again
have that experience i had no idea how
lucky i was
gone
and thank you very much
thank you for providing me an
opportunity for community input i am
representative sally fellows my district
is in grafton it includes holding this
hebron implement
there are three things i respectfully
ask you to consider
i have a suggestion that you might find
helpful and trying to keep all districts
within the 5 deviation limit
this is most likely to be useful in
counties with small populations where
the perfect seed allocation which is a
two-digit decimal number
includes a fraction close to one half
for example grafton county
when the population of 91
has a perfect allocation
of
[Music]
while i was able to successfully map
27 seats which is our current allocation
graphing with just a few adjustments to
the
current configuration
i couldn't map 26 seats even when using
three or four floaters and still keep
within the five percent deviation from a
what i discovered was that only three
seats were below the state target the
other 23 were over
the only only one district was outside
of the five percent wage and that one
was over by 5.47
so i'm wondering why so like lopsided
with 324
over since grafton's allocation of 26
seats is nearly half a percentage below
there are 1
extra people
that must be squished
into the 26 seats
that's an average of 61 extra people
or
1.7
of the target
for each seat
if that excess were evenly distributed
across all the seats
each would have a deviation of plus 1.76
the deviation
of that magnitude is more than one third
of the way to the maximum allowable
deviation of 5
so i think that's the key
you know when you have
a district whose percentage is is close
to an extra pass you have a lot of extra
seats that you
people that you have to deal with and
trying to get that within five percent
is very difficult
my suggestion is to develop county maps
based on the state average target of
244 people received
but
if a few seats are a bit outside that 5
limit
test the deviation using the target
that is the county population
divided by the number of county seats
if all the seats are within within the
five percent i suggest
my second request and you've heard this
one before
is that after preparing draft maps
please provide a second opportunity for
community input it's the people who live
in each town who know which other towns
are part of their community this is
particularly important for grafton
county because it does not have a
representative on the right
redistricting committee
and lastly
it seems to be generally accepted that
public schools are an important element
of shared interest
my third request is that instead of
using saus as the school link that you
use high school of attendance for each
town
the only common denominator that all
saus provides is shared by sau staff
some sauss don't include any high
schools
and some have districts that use
two different high schools
new hampshire department of education
publishes two high school lists but
neither of these have all the towns by
the high school that they
attend
i've developed a spreadsheet of that and
i can provide you with that spreadsheet
which you can easily sort by town or by
high school if you wish to use it
thank you
again on that oh
uh okay so uh
[Music]
speaking but oh listening to people i
i had the honor to serve this county as
the first economic developer
when the newly formed fellow county
economic development council was formed
in 1992.
we became a model of regional
development groups that now exist across
the state
a lot had to do with ray burton who
represented this area
and wanted to see what we had created as
accounting take part elsewhere in the
state
i returned to new hampshire after
serving for a brief period of time in
the civil war position in vermont
in 1992
we had unemployment in this region of
11.5
officially and closer to 17 and a half
percent unofficially belknap county had
a challenge what i quickly learned is
that the olympian municipalities were
exceedingly different in their needs
and visions as a delegation
there were differences
but we were able to work together
for the benefit of all
what i found helpful is i worked to
develop programs and initiatives as
representatives would share local
perspectives
they would understood their community
needs
i doubt the reps from guildford
could elaborate on the issues of
narrative
or vice versa i spend a lot of time i
live in guilford but i spent a lot of
time volunteering
in meredith i've been for a long time
um
in new hampshire
there are real differences between my
town when i was working what
tilting needed and what sanborn sanford
wanted
yet the rewarding part of all of this is
when the delegation truly represented
their talents we were able to come
together and we did some very great
things together we were the best wired
county
the state found in 1996.
we also put together municipal services
and the reason i feel we did this folks
is the fact that
every town had
a representative that really understood
their people and if there was a problem
i could take them to the company or i
could take them to the uh
non-profit organization in need of
health and
i'd like to see us return to that and
that they each have their own voice
and a person who really cares on them
so please consider that
we have a great state
and we are different uh i spent a lot of
time in vermont
but they're much closer closer to being
very similar of course i worked for a
[Music]
is
district on election day
and he did it and the way that shook out
was a minivan would pull in the side
door
[Music]
yes so my name is moe actually and i'm
from laconia um i hope to offer
testimony um tonight but it's not
possible off the testimony uh
legislation one language hasn't been
written
words available to the public
i understand the timeline
that this committee is under
legislatively
but i was asked and request that once
the maps are done
and the language is available um to the
public
even though there may not be time for
you to do another um
or
mistake in person that you hold the
hearing in contact or do one online so
that people can indeed offer testimony
uh
this one's easy nice sprite ruth larson
[Music]
um
really really brief the voters of new
hampshire and the voters of donald trump
have spoken regarding their votes in
favor of fair impartial
redistricting
it will be up to you as committee
members to be
as non-partisan as the voters have been
you have a choice
the choice is made sometimes in the past
have been less than non-partisan
no one can make you think about them it
will be up to you to do the right thing
and i have confidence that you will know
what the right thing is and you will do
and i'm here because i think that we
just have a big impact on the strength
and resiliency of our towns and
countries and state
and a foundation of those
characteristics is diversity
luckily recently retired but i worked
for several large corporations
where we thought diversity was really
important and a couple of reasons were
it gave us
a water challenge
so we could get really good employees
and that broader output also gave us
people with lots of different ideas
which helped us
produce better products
and make our businesses more resilient
i think the same thing applies to
politics
disenfranchising half of the people in
our state who could be bringing ideas
and energy
and
into our political process and giving us
better voter participation
and better
candidates as a result
um you have you that the
new hampshire business discipline
committee have a big responsibility
you'll be deciding how valued the voters
in new hampshire feel
over the next 10 years by being more
inclusive you can make new hampshire
stronger and more resilient
i like like the other people that have
spoken i hope that we get another chance
to see you i online would be fine and to
participate in the process and what work
you've done
and to make you know further influence
so but i really appreciate your time and
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
david
thank you mr chairman i won't take i
want to take long i will say however
we've done a lot of talking about names
here tonight
and i have to tell you about the time i
went to see doctor
and i walked into the room he was
sitting there and he said they call me
adam
and i said why would you want to call me
he said well he said my last name that's
14 letters of nobody
[Music]
and i said well everything about me my
i wasn't gonna wasn't saying anything
tonight but i haven't seen anybody
here
laconia uh has
an unusual problem uh
every person or phony is represented by
four representatives
so that means that uh
there are something in the vicinity of
uh 16 800
voters who all have the same
you have four representatives
and there's no different agent
that wasn't always the way i my first
time i served in the legislature was in
197 71
and i represented war ii divided by wars
you don't have to do it that way but it
doesn't seem right that the people in
europe
have 16 871
people representing no matter where they
live
but um
[Music]
but if you add
that population to 16 871
they have
23 25 23 000 or so people
perform forming one representative this
doesn't make a lot of sense
um
so i think that the
committee on a good hard look at how the
representation in the city of colleen is
constructed i realize it's difficult in
the city i've got a lot of different
factors involved
particularly with city awards
um but the words are there and
we're not allowed to change the world
lines in order to reduce it but
uh i would hope that the committee would
take a serious look
at
a forming district where
not quite so many people
have the same representative
thank you
good evening everybody and uh thank you
member to the remission company for the
opportunity to retire tonight thank you
also for taking your time as i'm sure
everybody in the room knows
you are the lowest paid employees in the
world
you guys are going to pay nothing for
the time that you put in taking your
evenings like this
to talk to us today is greatly
appreciated
it's unfortunate i know that some of the
members are missing tonight that for
today's technology we couldn't figure
out a way for them all to participate
but i myself do appreciate you coming
out here tonight taking your time to
listen to our concerns
my name is tony creator i've been a
resident of america for 30 years
i've been a resident in new hampshire
for 40 years is what i'm fond of saying
is i'm from new hampshire
but my parents are from massachusetts
i moved to new hampshire as soon as i
could i grew up massachusetts but i
always consider myself from new
hampshire i have i came here when i was
a kid i've always considered this to be
my home
last while i became far more attuned to
how things work
there and i'm not here to talk about
what's happening in lithuania or what's
happening at alton i'm not here to say
that you guys are not doing your job
intent for the residents of new
hampshire or you would not be running
and working like this for two years for
two hundred dollars let's face it you
guys don't get paid
you're doing this because you have the
best interest of the residents of the
state of new hampshire and i'm not here
to tell you how to do your job
but when she ran for for the house i
realized that
something just really didn't seem right
with the way guilford america's put
together i'm not a republican i'm not a
democrat i'm not going to talk about
gerrymandering i'm not going to talk
about somebody doing something and
compared with one party over the other
i'm not here to talk about politics i'm
here to talk about the town
the town of meredith and i read this and
i tried to fact-check it and i couldn't
really fact-check it that
was we've had our own representative
for 150 years i think it's more like 227
years the town of america was
incorporated in 1768 the house was
incorporated in 1784.
we had a representative from 1784 to
2011 to the fifth night to figure that's
227 years of the town of meredith had
its own representation
somehow we got tossed in with guilford
i don't know why i've asked a bunch of
people nobody knows why
if i was a cynic i would think that
something furry is happening to put
those two towns together but i'm not
here to complain or say that anybody did
anything without the best intent of mine
um the fact is as we've all heard the
town of mary and the town of guilford
share no land order as you can see on
the picture in front of you in order for
the people that are running for state
rep
to get to a common border they had a
paddle canoes out into the middle of
lakewood to get to a point
where the two towns met
in addition to that if you actually
wanted to drive
mario killford it's a 12 mile drive now
in the summertime when we have all the
several residents here and all the
tourists here that can be a half an hour
or more
to get to two towns that have been
combined together
for some unknown reason
in addition to that
they don't share any municipal
operations
they don't share any programs they don't
share any sports teams
they don't have any common commercial or
healthcare interests
so
how we ended up combining those two
towns with really kind of a question as
to what the motive was
if you were actually to look at towns
that actually had a common interest
guilford and wilmington actually share
a common interest but i'm not proposing
that we combine guilford and gillington
or any other combination
and with due respect to representative
silver's comment
we have a very easy solution
for meredith and gilbert we don't need
to blow up beyond the current number of
representatives and i'm sure this same
instance
occurs in other places
but i'm only going to talk about
american guild we have four
representatives
and we have approximately the same
population in the two towns now an
interesting thing also is that
if you would look at the property
valuations because let's face it that's
how we found ourselves there's three
property evaluations that let's take a
month
the town of meredith has 2.3 billion
dollars in evaluative home valuations we
ranked 19th in the state
town guilford has 2.1 billion they're
ranked 22nd in the state we each
contribute approximately 32 million
dollars to stakeholders
we contribute roughly the same amount of
money we have roughly the same property
tax valuation we have roughly the same
population
i don't think it's asking a lot for the
amount of money that we present to the
state on a yearly basis to say hey let's
take those four break it into two give
them their
representatives like the town of earth
has had for 227 years
and you don't have to blow anything up
all you have to do is take before we
why do we want to say okay we want to do
something different than they decided to
do in 2010 which now we continue to
figure out why they did it
it's
in a non-cannon to school anybody on the
same constitution you guys know it
better than anybody that's on the side
of the team
but if you look at the way it is right
now as representative silver said we
have three from guildford one for
meredith if something was to come to the
state that would harm meredith and
benefit guildford
guess how that's going to go
it's not going to go towards america
it's going to go towards guilford
we should not be ever setting up a
situation where we can disadvantage one
town over the other if we don't have to
and this is a case where we clearly
don't have to
i am strongly urging every member of
this committee i don't care what you do
it's representative of our population
it's representative of our tax base it's
representative of the amount of money we
that's all i'm asking for i appreciate
the time you guys are giving us tonight
i appreciate the time that you guys are
putting into this tonight and i am sure
that you are moving forward with the
everybody in the state of new hampshire
not just the people in guilford not just
people america but the people throughout
the entire city thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
all righty
sheet number two
representative
[Music]
um
um initiative
so i promised my voters i will bring
that to you and ask that you please do
that and knowing that i know you all
being my third term in the house i'm
sure you will do
that as well
um but one other thing i will speak
about i serve two towns they say the
town of san fran and the town of tilton
um
if you look at your your demographic map
there you'll see that they have 3 900 as
well within 3 44
needed and above the deviation mark so
i'm going to do something that most
politicians mostly always speak against
my self-interest
and i'm going to say i've asked you to
please put a record
um and use the overage that's until they
cover the town of salmon create a float
between the towns of children and
sandwiches the reason i think this is
still a good move is that the towns of
tilton sanderson share a lot of
communities and interests we share high
school we share a middle school we share
borders on the lake uh our the main
thoroughfare
[Music]
uh somebody so i have to tell me a story
about him
um
and this is a very unknown fact about
him but he happens
the best slot
in traffic
[Music]
so yeah um well we've heard a lot
tonight about uh
how
i'm from hillmanton we've heard a lot
tonight about how
uh
undemocratic uh the treatment of
gambling has been
uh with the gerrymandering
uh and
the fact that we don't have the state
representative uh i'd like to invoke uh
geography and history to argue uh how
problematic that situation is um
well
i think we all we all know that we're in
a special place as i was coming here uh
you know the sun was staying over over
the golden russet leaves
uh but another another thing that's
that's very special about this part of
the world
is that it's it's really
the place where american democracy is
always the most
uh
[Music]
norman rockwell freedom of speech
uh
and uh this just beginnings from 1943
uh and it kind of counts as an actual
person you're working in and
jim edgerton
standing up in the town meeting in
arlington vermont where
rockler lived
for many years
and
edmonton was a political dissenter
um
after school burned down
in arlington he was the only one to
oppose building a new one
um
he's poor probably the most people in
this uh drawing in his in his painting
um
and
his hands are probably dirtier
you know if political forces were
strategizing against him if there were
something like gerrymandering town
he might not be able to speak
but he is speaking and everyone in this
room is looking at him in this room
right here is looking up at him
appreciatively and listening
and these people are not only honoring
democracy
they're honoring history
uh democracy is so central tenant to new
england
that when the french writer alexis de
tocqueville in the
1830s
uh
right
doing research for his
very famous book democracy and america
he looked at the town meeting the new
england town meeting
meetings like this one in this picture
and he wrote in the laws of new england
we find the life and mainstream of
american liberty
wrote that the town meeting was a thing
you know in the england as early as 1650
and he marveled at the democracy which
was a cutting-edge concept when it was
suspended back in
[Music]
you know rolled the rocks uh
the side of the field to build stone
walls
and uh
um
in this and this is according to tokyo
in this community so humble
a man might stand up in the face of a
free people and embrace liberty
my point is this
tonight we were talking about some very
small towns but a large issue
let's do the right thing let's respect
women's history
let's respect democracy and let's ensure
that kilmington has its own
representative thank you
[Music]
i will not be trapped by this valid
combination so last
testimony where the last name has been
vice chair smith uh chairman gray and
members of the registration committee my
name is brian neal i'm deputy director
of open democracy action
a non-partisan nonprofit working on
pro-voter reforms here in new hampshire
we were founded by doris granny haddock
whose mission it was to end special
interest control of government and
return it to the hands of people
i live in alton
after spending 35 years in the monadnock
region
you've been seeing a lot of me lately
and i'd like to spend a few minutes
talking about why that is
and
then i'd like to make a proposition
throughout this year and part of the
last year i've been engaged in educating
the public on their distance process
what it means to have a fair process and
ways to get better maps create better
maps that have been produced and have
been produced in the last few decades
we've run workshops about the best
practices for fair redistricting
featuring national experts which some of
you have attended
we've educated towns about our
constitutional provisions for
redistricting and we with our partners
assembled the macrophage coalition in
which over 250 people have now
volunteered
we helped 74 towns around the state from
red towns like all franklin londonderry
and ridge to blue towns like lebanon
lebanon durham and keane and every color
in between
those 74 towns represented
561 000 granite staters
with only five losses
it was only the that's
beyond the 704
with only five losses it was only
available time in the pandemic that kept
that number from being a super majority
of new hampshire voters
they varied slightly in language but
those cities and towns were asking for a
fair non-partisan and transparent
process
you can nitpick about it being a
non-bonding resolution
but tell that to the voters who braved
the pandemic to come off the photon
making it clear they wanted fair mass
and i'd say they took it very seriously
in may the mapathon coalition began to
work surveying new hampshire cities and
towns for communities of interest data
what we didn't get through surveys we
followed up by phone calls to counter
administrators this yielded a list of 60
communities of interest
um which the larger map of the
participants whittled down to fire
the all-volunteer mapping and technical
team was formed as a subset to this
larger group and comprised of engineers
data analysts software specialists and
taking that criteria our mapping and
technical team assembled community of
interest maps from the state of new
hampshire's department of education
department of environmental services
department of health and human services
and federal and academic sources this
helped us to create the overlays that
you see on our maps of the regional high
schools healthcare regions regional
planning districts
uh shared municipal water and sewer
shared police and fire and a couple of
them excuse me a couple of others
it's important to note that these
overlays can be used with anyone's maps
as they are available through the ask
in addition to the overlays members of
the mapathon mapping and tech team
created analysis tools which can test
our maps and the maps of others to see
with where
there are weaknesses mistakes or
intentional uh manipulation
like joel and by mr joel anderson's
software one of our team members phil
hatcher developed a computer software
tool which makes mapping suggestions
based on new hampshire and u.s
constitutional mandates and other
factors
this has been a useful tool which has
already made some suggestions that we
hadn't thought of
while our maps are not perfect
as my colleague john cross discussed
last night
the
communities of interest
can be implemented and retain
um excuse me i lost my weight here
as my colleague
john cross
discussed last night we've proven that
communities of interest can be
implemented to retain high schools
shared water systems healthcare regions
and regional planning etc some of which
you've heard asked for in these hearings
this community of interest data along
with our maps and supporting
documentation is readily accessible to
the committee to both communities
tonight i'd like to take one more step
and make a proposition in consultation
with the mapathon mapping and technical
team earlier today we are offering our
services to the two committees
the house special committee is up
against a tight demo
our house maps are nearing completion as
close as we can get to them
without
the completed
redistricted city words
we can work with you side by side
and joining your policy and
constitutional expertise with our
technical expertise
i have confidence that we uh can help
this house special committee meet its
deadlines
uh allow for a seven-day review period
and produce a worthy product
while our dra 2020 software had a
limitation of being able to show for
period districts this problem has now
dra software allows for the manipulation
excuse me manipulation implementation of
many useful tools including overlays
additional data sets and other tools not
available in mr anderson's software
while the senate has more time to create
senate and executive council maps we
have proposals ready to analyze which
improve competitiveness and compactness
while being sensitive to communities of
communities of interest
new hampshire has a long tradition of
volunteer contributions to developing
legislation i'm hoping that the house
and senate committee will give out our
serious offer of technical support
consideration and together we can share
maps that we can all be proud of at
future narratives
thank you for your time and service to
our state uh for being committed to a
fair nonpartisan and transparent process
and for logging all of these miles to
listen to the input of your constituents
thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
so
ladies and gentlemen if anybody didn't
sign up that does want to speak
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we do have somebody
who does want to testify so
and um
gently
evening
um
madam chair and members of the special
redistribution committee
uh my name is jim mcfarland from
meredith and i volunteered to create a
warranty at our march town meeting for
the new hampshire resolution
for fair nonpartisan and transparent
redistricting
in 2021.
as in 74 other towns this resolution was
passed overwhelmingly
by meredith's voters
this is a powerful and clear message to
your committee
that voters across political spectrum
care deeply
that this once every decade
redistricting be done fairly
and impartially
with no gerrymander
our district 2 representative jonathan
matthews
testified at our marchtown meeting on
the record
to support a restored merit to our own
district
with our own exclusive representative
transparency is crucial to restore voter
confidence lost
in 2011 partisan
secretive and unfair redistricting
which favored the party in power
transparency means the following
software algorithms and criteria that
will be used
must be public
why is this not yet available
number two 2020 census data for
redistricting must be shared fully and
openly
with the public
why is this not so
number three committee meetings must be
open to the public with at least seven
days advance notice
detailed redistricting committee meeting
minutes must be promptly posted
publicly
the hearings and listening sessions
should be live streamed
and recorded and available on the
committee's website
so that they are widely accessible
your meetings
and county listening sessions like this
one
should be on zoomed to allow those
unable physically to attend
to safely participate
why are you not allowing this during a
pandemic
this committee must release your draft
maps
with sufficient time
for public review and response
proposed drafts of maps must be shown at
a second
county listening sessions across the
state
for public response before they are
voted on and adopted
soliciting the contributions and review
by professional nonpartisan
redistricting experts
to assist the committee
with the process structure and criteria
employed in redistricting talented as
the preceding speaker just proposed an
your mass must force the middle to the
legislature
for final vote to approve
it must have a consensus of approval
from new hampshire's voters
without this voter trust in you our
leaders and democracy will further
deteriorate
you can and must restore your voter
space
and defend democracy in new hampshire
no gerrymandering
honor your role
specific to meredith per the november 7
2006 constitutional amendment
on new hampshire house redistricting
your committee must honor this amendment
and restore meredith to our own district
with our own exclusive house
representatives
to do otherwise is to perpetuate the
injustice
inflicted on emeritus voters in 2011
depriving us of our rightful
representation
each individual member of this pretty
critically important committee
must call upon
your own good consciousness
consider your legacy
and choose to defend rather than destroy
democracy
in new hampshire
you must put aside the partisan pursuit
of power
and provide proof you can create truly
fair matters
is there anyone else that wants to